[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue aura
vite vous retrouvez en direct comme
toujours avec deux invités pour débattre
autour de l'actualité bonsoir laurent
alexandre le soir vous êtes médecin
entrepreneurs et céistes votre dernier
livre jouissez jeunesse a été publié aux
éditions lattès bonsoir alexandre de
vote soit vous êtes responsable des
pages débats du figaro magazine vous
avez d'ailleurs signé dans le dernier
numéro du fig mag un entretien avec le
professeur didier lemaire professeur
trappe qui sonnent l'alarmé sur les
ravages du communautarisme dans cette
ville et dans son établissement
vous êtes aussi d'auteurs de
recomposition le nouveau monde populiste
ouvrage publié aux éditions du cerf
j'espère chers amis internautes que vous
n'aviez pas l'intention d'aller passer
votre prochain week end sur la côte
d'azur à nice parce que sinon il faudra
changer vos plans avec la progression du
virus le préfet des alpes-maritimes
vient d'annoncer un recond finement
partiel voici les détails expliqué par
l'intéressé c'était en fin de matinée la
situation épidémique actuel impose
également une restriction des
déplacements et donc un confinement
partiel alors pour les deux week-ends à
venir
les déplacements seront interdits dans
les communes de l'air urbaine littoral
les rurbains littoral c'est cette zone
qui s'étend de menton à théoule sur mer
et qu'ils consentent près de 90% de la
population du département
les autres qui est le principal lieu de
contamination
laurent alexandre c'était la bonne
décision pour ne pas le choix c'est à
dire que dans les zones où le taux de
contamination augmente on est obligés
aujourd'hui de de sévir alors ça tombe
mal parce que c'est aujourd'hui
qu'israël des confiné réouvre tout
puisque israël a quasiment fini son
programme vaccinal puisque 87% il ya 87
% d'injection en israël et l'immense
majorité des populations à risque ont
maintenant eu les deux injections en
israël et donc nous avec notre programme
de
six nations et ce cargo du fait des
erreurs de l'union européenne dans les
commandes de vaccins on se retrouve à
reconfirmer des zones au moment où les
pays qui ont vacciné rapidement des
confine le symbole il est politiquement
terrible à un an de la présidentielle de
2000 22
c'est nouveau c'est inédit même
alexandre devait que ce confinement
partiel alors ça existait déjà mais dans
les territoires d'outre-mer en métropole
c'est c'est la première fois que ça
intervient le gouvernement a hésité on
attendait hier soir là la décision du
pouvoir vous pensez que il avait des
doutes sur la l'acceptabilité comme on
dit aujourd'hui d'une telle mesure
peut-être qu emmanuel macron était dans
une logique plutôt en ce moment de
déconfinement que de que d'euros
confinement est sans doute que c'est lui
qui a peut-être freiné avant que la
décision soit prise puisque les zélés
une partie des élus locaux principal élu
local local christian estrosi était
favorable se confirme on peut d'ailleurs
se demander s'il n'y a pas une
expérimentation territoriales mais aussi
une expérimentation politique avec un
début de fusion l air l hérault m
dans cette région en tout cas on sait ce
que c'est ce que souhaitent christian
estrosi mais admettons que la situation
sanitaire l'exigé et que monsieur
estrosi soit au dessus de ces
considérations bassement politiciennes
sans doute sommes-nous au pied du mur
elle sans doute n'y a pas le choix que
de prendre ce type de mesure dans
l'urgence même s'il a encore oublié un
défaut de d'anticipation nés pendant les
vacances scolaires peut-être qu'on
aurait pu le faire avant que les gens
débarquent à nier j'ai des doutes aussi
sur le fait de confiner spécifiquement
le littoral c'est les gens qui habitent
à nier sont parfois des maisons
secondaires dans l'arrière-pays il irait
tout simplement contaminé l'arrière-pays
donc voilà c'est de la dentelle
gestation que soient hyper hyper
efficace non moi ce qui me ce que je
trouve inquiétant c'est qu'on banalise
totalement cette histoire de confinement
l'impression qu'on ne va jamais en
sortir aussi bien à nice que sur le plan
national du confinement des profils mans
je rappelle qu'en réalité même si
emmanuel macron je disais tout à l'heure
on joue la carte plutôt de la liberté en
réalité quand il ya un couvre-feu à 18
heures on est quasiment dans une
situation de confinement donc je rejoins
ce qui a été dit sur les vaccins on voit
bien que c'est un échec logistique total
sur la campagne vaccinale est d'ailleurs
sur tous les plans qui fait que la
france s'enfonce dans cette crise et moi
ce que j'aimerais voir ces hommes
politiques qui réfléchissent désormais à
une issue et ça on ne le voit pas
personne ne nous garantit que la
stratégie vaccinale on n'a pas de
calendrier pour savoir quand est-ce
qu'on espère sortir de cette crise
grecque avec les variants voilà emmanuel
sortent pas ces maillots le maquereau a
promis laurent alexandre 1 à la fin de
l'été tous les français adultes qui le
souhaitent auront été vaccinés ça
devrait vous réjouir ça oui enfin des
restaurants sont déjà fermés depuis
quatre mois
donc on est dans une situation de
contrainte énorme et le retard qu'on a
pris sur le plan vaccinal en europe est
tellement gigantesque qu'en réalité on
va être dans les situations israélienne
à l'automne donc on a des mois et des
mois de sacrifices devant nous donc la
situation va être très très pénibles
évidemment que macron souhaiterait des
confiné mais macron sait bien qu'il n'a
pas de vaccin est ce que nous enseigne
le laboratoire israélien parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses très intéressantes
sur ce qui s'est passé en israël c'est
qu'avec le développement des nouveaux
variants et en israël le variant
britanniques et les variants exotiques
ont dépassé 70% des
des parts de marché du virus il faut
monter très haut dans la vaccination
pour voir une amélioration des courbes
de mortalité et d'hospitalisation grave
c'est pas mon vaccinant 10-15 % des
israéliens qu on a vu une amélioration
de la situation sanitaire
on a vu la situation l'amélioration
tardive alors allez maintenant
spectaculaire mais elle a été tardive ce
qui veut dire pour la france qu'on va
voir un mieux grâce à la vaccination
tardivement
sans doute mais juin probablement pas
avant puisqu'on est encore en phase
d'explosion du variant britannique en
france qui est en train d'atteindre 40 %
en ile-de-france
donc ça va être très dur à gérer pour le
pouvoir oui et encore on est dans une
course contre la montre face aux
variants donc il ya aussi une
possibilité moi je crois plutôt à une
sortie de crise en octobre si tout se
passe bien et si le vaccin est toujours
efficace face face aux variants donc
donc il sera temps d'aller d'accélérer
et surtout de deux publiquement je pense
que ce sera rassurant parce que les
français peuvent accepter des efforts
même à la date que jusqu'en octobre mais
si on leur dit sur lui explique pour son
euro explique pourquoi
et si vraiment on a l'espoir d'une
sortie définitive de cette crise est là
dessus voilà l'exécutif n'est pas très
clair pas très pas très rassurant donc
ça nous promet des mois moroses et
surtout une france dont le déclin on a
déjà vu qu'elle était en déclarant par
plein d'aspects dans cette crise mais
dont le déclin sera achevé au sortir de
la crise parce que plus haut sans tarder
ivement plus les conséquences
économiques sociales vont être il faut
savoir que les chiliens ou les serbes
sans parler des israéliens vaccine six
fois plus vite que les français donc
effectivement les pays comme la france
sont très en retard et macron c'est bien
qu'il n'aura pas de dose rational à
cause des erreurs qui ont été faites et
ça doit le paniqué parce que les
sacrifices vont s'étendre vont durer et
il n'est pas exclu que la population
n'ait vraiment ras-le-bol
alors vous êtes juste que des sols et
les blés britannique
las de ce que j'entends justement boris
johnson est en train de d'expliquer
quiconque on entre dans une sortie de
crise il ya 15 millions de personnes
vaccinées
s'il assure beaucoup plus vite que nous
et de manière générale on a parlé
d'israël les pays souverain maître
maîtres de leur destin où on était plus
rapide dans cette campagne vaccinale que
que l'europe est encore plus que la
france qui en plus est le mauvais élève
de l'europe puisque on rappellera que la
serbie pas plus que le royaume uni
désormais des membres de l'union
européenne
vos commentaires sont assez contrastés à
l'image d'ailleurs de ces petits
sondages qui n'en sont pas puisque vous
n'êtes pas un échantillon représentatif
si ce n'est des gens de qualité qui nous
regardaient sur twitter vous a posé la
question fallait-il re confiné nice etc
oui à 59% alors que sur youtube où vous
pouvez nous suivre en direct les
résultats sont un peu inversés c'est à
dire c'est non à 69 %
donc il n'ya pas de d'enseignement
forcément attiré en revanche vos
commentaires sont toujours aussi
passionnant merci à gisèle sur youtube
qui nous rappelle que nice est composé à
30 % de seniors
et elle ajoute les vaccinés serait plus
opportun que les confiner il ya un
internaute sur lefigaro.fr qui est
d'accord avec alexandre ii vecchio tout
ça parce que christian estrosi veut bien
se faire voir de mâcon mais un autre
internaute un petit peu plus critique
mon cher alexandre qui vous dit c'est le
roux sur lefigaro.fr dans l'arrière pays
qui vous rencontrer les habitants
il n'y a personne tant que donc
peut-être moins de risques de
contamination chardon bleu considère
tout simplement sur le figaro.fr que
tout est un échec
et puis un anonyme sur lefigaro.fr on
veut finit par confiner les français
parce qu'on n'a pas voulu contrôler les
frontières dès l'apparition des variants
c'est vrai que christian estrosi pour en
revenir à lui indiqué hier que
moment des fêtes de fin d'année le
nombre d'avions à l'aéroport de nice
s'est passé 20 à 120 par jour ce qui n'a
pas dû on peut ajouter que ça continue
et que théoriquement on contrôler les
frontières mais aux aéroports les gens
arrivent
il n'y a pas de on l'aimé pas
l'isolément donc
donc il faut parfois aussi se donner les
moyens d'appliquer les mesures que l'on
propose que parmi ces moyens il y aurait
où il y aura une fois qu'une partie
importante de la population aura été
vaccinées le fameux passeport sanitaire
vous avez qui permettrait de se déplacer
plus librement peut-être d'avoir accès à
davantage de services au départ la
majorité des français était plutôt
content
peut-être que la situation est en train
d'évoluer écoutez cette réflexion
d'odile launay elle est infectiologues
et membre du comité vaccin qu'ovide 19
mois j'ai été plutôt défavorable aux
passeports vaccinale mais on voit bien
que ces leçons aux lycéens
oui parce que les compagnies aériennes
vont le demander certains pays vende
demande est donc très probablement
est-ce que ça va être un passeport
vaccinale est ce que ça va être un
passeport immunitaire c'est-à-dire
montrer qu'on a des anticorps c'est
probable qu'on va arriver à quelque
chose comme ça au moins de façon
temporaire
alexandre ii vecchio le passeport
sanitaires vous êtes plutôt pour plutôt
contre bon moi je veux c'est pas que je
vous botter en touche mais elle parlait
du passeport de sanitaires quand on a
pas de vaccin je trouve ça assez
paradoxal et même ça quelque chose
d'énervant en israël quoi que la
majorité des gens étaient contre et
finalement il s'est imposé presque
naturellement parce qu'ils ont
effectivement été nommé trials on a été
à est vacciné bon niveau au dessus
duquel on pourrait mettre le passeport
50 70 ces critiques moi si j'étais un
homme politique c'est le genre de
mesure qu'on met en place et qu'on
décide quand on a enfin des résultats
sur leur s est beaucoup plus acceptable
a lancé un débat là-dessus maintenant à
part clivé la population accroître la
décision je ne vois pas l'intérêt
donc voilà je botte un peu en touche par
dos mais je pense qu'il ya un débat qui
se posera quand on aura le vaccin
d'ailleurs pour l'instant le
gouvernement ne parle pas de ce sujet
c'est plutôt les observateurs les
médecins le gouvernement ne veut pas en
parler pour une raison très simple c'est
que comme on vaccine à la vitesse de
l'escargot
il ya très très peu de gens qui
pourraient avoir le passeport vaccinale
en israël on donne le passeport
vaccinale une semaine après la deuxième
injection
des gens qui ont eu la deuxième
injection en france il y en a quasiment
pas donc le passeport vaccinale ne
serait qu'à quelques centaines de
milliers de français et donc ça créerait
des jalousies énorme
norel n'aurait le droit d'aller au
restaurant qu'une toute petite élite
vacciner c'est à dire que quelques
pourcents de la france et donc c'est
difficile de mettre en place le
passeport vaccinale quand la stratégie
de vaccination a échoué est si lente
cela dit moi à titre personnel et pas
parce que j'ai été doublement vacciner
en tant qu' en tant que médecin mais je
pense que l'avantagé passeport vaccinale
c'est de réouvrir la vie de réouvrir un
sérum de restaurants de réouvrir des
cafés et de réouvrir les cinémas ses
dires de permettre même si tout le monde
n'y a pas le droit de recréer un petit
peu de vie et de re de de réouvrir les
espaces de liberté les espaces culturels
et en plus ça donne une visibilité et r
les gens peuvent voir à quel moment ils
auront le passeport vaccinale est donc à
quelle date ils vont pouvoir retourner
au bistrot ou au restaurant donc moi
personnellement aujourd'hui je suis
favorable
on passe au passeport vaccinale même si
ça peut créer un sentiment d'injustice
parce que ça permet de faire revivre
tout le tissu associatif tout le tissu
des restaurants des lieux de vie
je pense qu'on peut commencer à y penser
sans passeport vaccinale mais en plus on
voit bien que pardonnez moi je pense que
ça tient pas à part en cas de
vaccination de masse qu'elle va être
l'intérêt pour le restaurateur de
rouvrir s'il sait pour toute petite
partie de la population sauf si
effectivement mais qui ont des
restaurants des restaurants extrêmement
cher réservé à une petite élite donc ça
c'est c'est autre chose
je déconseille quand même aux hommes
politiques de se lancer là dedans
connaissant le passé révolutionnaire de
la france l'atmosphère
parce que ce sera dangereux alors
pardonnez ma curiosité mais comme vous
nous fait l'amitié de nous donner une
information personnelle en disant que
vous vous êtes fait vacciner est-ce que
vous qui êtes très très au fait de ce
sujet vous avez demandé un mac simple
qu'un autre all eyez heures au
modern'bar moi je suis allé dans un
centre où on donnait le preiser j'aurais
aussi bien pu prendre le modern à
l'efficacité du finder et du moderna des
deux vaccins arn messagers très
supérieur à l'efficacité de la stran eca
on le voit très bien quand on regarde
les chiffres israélien où il n'y a eu
que les vaccins arn messager qui ont été
utilisées donc moi personnellement je
n'aurais pas voulu de l'astra zeneca
compte tenu de ces performances moins
bonnes mais ça pose un vrai problème
d'équité à l'intérieur de nos nations
dire que on va avoir plus de vaccins
moyens médiocre que de bons messagers
mais pour une raison très simple c'est
que quand les vaccins ont été présentés
par l'industriel personne ne croyait que
les vaccins arn messager était aussi
révolutionnaire est aussi efficace
personne n'y croyait et les gens
d'ailleurs avait peur des vaccins arn
messager donc on a commandé beaucoup de
vaccins traditionnels et pas tant que ça
de bon vaccin arn messager êtes vous
pour le passeport sanitaires on vous a
posé la question sur twitter etc non
mais à une majorité assez courte puisque
c'est non à 52%
giovanni par exemple sur youtube et
contre il considère que c'est une
entrave à la liberté de circulation et
ce qui est un rôle fondamental est un
pilier de la démocratie
il ne faut pas exclure la partie de la
population qui ne sera pas vacciner
le cousin du petit prince quel joli
pseudo toujours sur youtube un passeport
pour vivre dans son propre pays mais
dans quel monde vit-on
et puis patricia sur youtube nous sommes
plus de trois millions et demi de
français
guéri du coc vide avec des anticorps
donc et surtout non vaccinable on ne
nous prend pas en compte et chardons
bleus sur lefigaro.fr considère que
pourquoi pas éventuellement un vaccin
pour quitter la france un pardon un
passeport salutaire pour qualifier la
france mais pas pour aller au restaurant
alors le restaurant parlons-en encore
que ce sont pas les meilleurs en tout
cas c'est la réputation qu'elles ont les
cantines scolaires pardon de cette
transition un peu laborieuse vous avez
peut-être que depuis ce matin à lyon les
petits enfants ne peuvent plus manger de
viande il y en a plus au menu le maire
europe ecologie les verts de lyon
grégory doucet indique que c'est la
pandémie qui entraîne ce changement de
menus tout simplement parce que ne pas
avoir de viande s'est facilité la
préparation des plateaux et il ajoute
que son prédécesseur gérard collomb
avait fait la même chose lors du premier
confinement sauf que beaucoup
soupçonnent europe ecologie les verts
d'avoir imposé pour des raisons
idéologiques ses menus sans viande ces
menus végétariens
c'est un petit peu ce que soupçonne
gabriela talent le porte parole du
gouvernement
je lui avais posé la question hier au
grand jury rtl le figaro lci
ce qu'ils disent c'est que parce qu'il
faut alléger enfin renforcer plutôt le
protocole sanitaire à la cantine il faut
un menu unique et que c'est plus simple
de faire comme ça et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui avait été fait il ya un an par la
mairie qui n'était pas alors europe
ecologie les verts et ils disent
eux-mêmes que dès qu'ils le pourront ils
reviendront sur des menus qui
permettront de donner le choix aux
élèves si c'est ça dont acte mais encore
une fois il faut pas que ce soit une
décision idéologique et que entre
guillemets la crise sanitaire servent à
ne plus laisser le choix aux enfants
alors on ne peut pas savoir
il faut croire sur parole le maire
europe ecologie les verts de lyon
laurent alexandre mais est ce que il ya
une ia
une espèce d'idéologie quand même de
ceux de ceux de ses menus végétariens ça
il ya un projet politique derrière ça
pour vous on sait qu'une bonne partie
des gens chez europe écologie sont
plutôt vegan et pense que manger de la
viande ça augmente le co2 quand vous
lisez tous les manuels d'écologie
moderne
on vous explique que le mangeur de
viande est un [ __ ] et on regarde les
gens qui vont acheter une entrecôte avec
un air suspicieux donc oui il ya une
dimension écologique c'est vrai que
manger de la viande ça à émettre plus de
co2 que de manger des carottes en tant
que carnivores
personnellement je pense qu'une france
sans viande sans élevage 100 vaches en
moutons sans agriculteurs où on ne
mangerait plus que que du soja serait
profondément profondément triste
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a derrière mais on
ne l'a pas beaucoup parlé sauf dans les
réseaux sociaux il ya en réalité une
autre raison c'est qu'il ya une
opposition des parents entre ceux qui
volent que la viande soit halal et ceux
qui ne veulent pas que la viande soit
halal parce qu'on a des parents qui
souhaiteraient que la viande que mangent
leurs enfants a été a été endormi avant
d'être abattu et inversement pour les
parents plutôt d'origine musulmane qui
comme vous savez sont majoritaires dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'écoles de la région
lyonnaise donc il ya une opposition
difficile à gérer entre les pros à
l'aller les anti hallal et le plus
simple pour régler le problème du halal
dans une école c'est d'interdire la
viande questions au dr alexandre c'est
gênant pour un enfant pas manger de
viande alors on peut si on a un régime
très équilibré on peut se passer de la
viande mais c'est très difficile chez
les enfants et ce à une contrepartie
c'est que ça diminue la taille des
enfants à l'âge adulte dire si nous
avons beaucoup grandi au 20e siècle
c'est parce que notre ration protidique
a beaucoup augmenté et c'est compliqué
d'avoir avec un régime vegan d'avoir
suffisamment de protides pour être
grande que si on généralise et le régime
vegan chez les petits on peut on peut
prédire qu'on aura une baisse de la
taille des petits français à l'horizon
2030 avec 102 véhicules
les écologistes et le
et le vg pas comment est ce qu'on dit le
végétarianisme en tout cas le véganisme
qui en est la version la plus absolue
c'est une histoire de d'affinités
profond oui il ya toute une idéologie et
si même on va jusqu'au bout de leur
raisonnement certains sont anti species
c'est à dire qu' il ne veut plus d'eux
abolir toute différence entre l'homme et
l'animal les auteurs on ne tue pas d
homme en tue pas les animaux est
exactement
enfin les plus radicaux comparé
l'abattage des animaux à la choix de la
soirée d'où les attaques de boucherie et
c'est maintenant je ne fais pas non plus
de procès d'intention ce pas tous les
écolos je suppose qu'ils pensent à a
priori la mairie de lyon n'a pas était
dans cette direction je crois assez à la
thèse peut-être de de laurent alexandre
qui a aussi une gestion communautaire
des choses une manière finalement de
simplifier enfin les la fin de
contourner les profils communautaires
possible avec cette mesure
voir une gestion clientéliste parce que
là on peut leur faire quand même pas des
procès d'intention mais pour le coup ils
ont montré quand ils sont arrivés au
pouvoir
les écolos le maire de lyon qui a refusé
d'aller à la fête des échevins mais qui
a inauguré une mosquée en parallèle on a
même un qui est une fête catholique
était une tradition tous les élus il y
allait parce que c'était culturel il ya
une volonté si les écolos de s'attaquer
à nos traditions
tout à l'heure vous parler de la france
en particulier de lyon c'est quand il ya
un gros un haut lieu de la gastronomie
ça fait partie quasiment de l'identité
française et on sent assez écolo bobo
des grandes métropoles qu'il n'aime pas
l'identité française ça n'était la même
chose à bordeaux avec le sapin de noël
c'était le prétexte était le bois mort
de trois enfants
le tour de france et sera donc voilà etc
ils ont fait enfin sont un peu des
récidivistes donc là on peut les
soupçonner voilà de vouloir faire table
rase du pain du passé de penser que nos
agriculteurs notre gastronomie
finalement c'est le jeu monde un peu un
peu dégoûtant et puis le nouveau mons et
de flatter les communautaristes d'un
côté et puis de passer au végétarianisme
voir au avait gagné cela il ya une
tendance comme ça chez les écolos qui
est assez inquiétant les internautes du
figaro ne semble pas être trop tenter
par cet écolo boboïsme que vous décrivez
cher alexandre ii vecchio c'est la
question du jour approuvez vous la
décision du maire de lyon d'imposer un
menu sans viande dans les écoles etc non
à 84%
c'était plus exactement la question du
jour hier sur le figaro.fr en somme un
considère lui que c'est juste imposer
une bonne hygiène de vie que ne pas
manger de viande à chaque repas ne veut
pas dire être végétarien philippe sur
twitter déplore qu'on mélange la
politique à la nutrition
il ne voit pas ce qui peut en sortir de
bon quand il mange des bonnes choses il
faut dire moi des souvenirs que j'en ai
c'est que c'est assez infâme
donc quand on est dans une belle région
comme liu pourrait justement en période
de crise économique ça retravailler les
agriculteurs locaux les producteurs
locaux et c'est ça ce sera une bonne
politique en plus une politique écolo
puisque quand on fait du local il ya
moins des changes
il n'est pas dit que dans ses cantines
n'y est pas des fruits qui viennent du
bonhomme
donc voilà ce sera beaucoup plus
cohérent et beaucoup plus écolo de
proposer et utile sur le plan économique
de proposer ce type de politique je
constate aussi de manière générale que
le repas était je crois en moyen
d'intégration de lutter contre les
différences en tout cas un moment
convivial où tout le monde se pouvait se
retrouver maintenant je me dis que c'est
de plus en plus compliqué hormis le cas
de lyon d'organiser des repas de famille
parce que entre ceux qui veulent manger
halal casher ceux qui sont végétariens
etc
c'est amusant les fractures françaises
se retrouvent même dans l'assiette donc
donc c'est aussi une évolution qui est
assez déplaisante et qui rend la vie je
crois
là je vous rejoins beaucoup plus triste
qu'elle ne l'était christine se demande
sur youtube ci après la viande il y aura
aussi les produits laitiers
a priori non c'est parce que c'est pas
ce qui est prévu et le maire de lyon a
dit que dans une prochaine période quand
la situation sera redevenue normale
les enfants pourront avoir le choix et
encore une réaction celle de gilles sur
youtube qui
nous dit que les substituts à la viande
coûte plus cher les apports en fer sont
vitaux est d'autant plus durant la
croissance des enfants
et puis cette remarque d'un anonyme sur
le figaro.fr
safra d'excellents jockey français d'ici
à 2040 allusions de laurent à l'accent
sur l'impact du manque de viande sur la
croissance des enfants
est ce qu'il ya une question de
génération dance est dans ce rapport à
la nourriture laurent l'exemple vous
êtes l'auteur d'un livre s'appelle
jouissez jeunesse est ce que c'est un
phénomène à votre avis plus sociologique
ou c'est un phénomène générationnel se
ce succès quand même dû du véganisme et
tous crins de du point de vue des
écologistes qui est quand même une
dimension sociologique dire que les
écologistes sont des peine à jouir
chaque fois qu'une petite jouissent à
une petite jouissance de la vie veulent
la supprimer
le tour de france les sapins de noël
donc il ya une dimension sado-maso chez
les écologistes français en tout cas
ceux qui ont pris le pouvoir dans les
municipalités qui est très frappant dès
qu'il ya un truc qui fait plaisir et qui
amuse les gens ils volent le supprimer
donc cette cette lutte contre la
jouissance me paraître l'adn des
écologistes moderne il y avait eu
patrouille de france c'est un exemple
aussi parce qu'on a parlé du tour de
france de la fête des échevins du sapin
de noël mais il avait fait aussi la
patrouille de france qui ne pouvaient
pas survolé lions donc oui il ya une une
détestation effectivement des
réjouissances populaires et même de
l'identité française
voilà il avait expliqué quand même je
fais l'avocat de la défense que c'était
pour éviter aux îles et les
rassemblements de gens puisque c'était
pendant le politique assez élitiste
parce que les écoles accueillent parfois
des enfants de deux classes populaires
modestes qui ne mange pas toujours
devions de la maison qu'à l'école est là
encore
là encore oui moi je joue a été
favorable justement à ce que l'école
soit un lieu d'éducation au bon goût
voilà la qualité de vie aussi pour ça
que voilà c'est une vraie politique
écologique ce serait de de s'appuyer sur
les produits du terroir dans les
cantines voilà à peu opinion que partage
olivine à sur youtube il ya des enfants
dont c'est le seul repas complet par
jour bataille idéologique ne se joue pas
avec l'estomac de nos enfants je trouve
ça indécent
quant à chardon bleu sur lefigaro.fr il
en a marre de ces écolos vegan il veut
manger du saucisson et du boeuf
bourguignon peut-être un exercice de
prévision
est-ce que vous pensez que cet
engouement pour lever gagnent 7
ce rejet de l'alimentation animale c'est
une mode qui passera ou c'est une
tendance de fond de nos sociétés
occidentales depuis que je suis rentré
en faculté de médecine il ya maintenant
plus de 40 ans j'ai connu cette vague
alimentaire successives la dernière
étant la folie du gluten ou on a
convaincu une large partie des français
qu'ils soient intolérants au gluten
alors que l'intolérance au gluten ne
touche qu'un français sur 1000 donc moi
je suis très zen
j'attends la huitième vague je sais
qu'il y aura d'autres vagues
il y a dans le domaine alimentaire des
succession de vagues parfois un peu
hystérique il faut attendre que sartre
que ça retombe et attendre la la vague
suivante
sauf que c'est pas seulement une
habitude alimentaire il ya derrière une
idéologie qui peut aller vous le disiez
oui c'est jusqu'à l'antispécisme je
pense qu'il faut pas sous-estimer
totalement les écolos notamment les
écolos bobos urbains certes ça touche
peut-être où j'ai vu les résultats des
municipales on voit que en réalité on
fait des scores beaucoup plus faible
qu'on le dit d'abord ça fait du monde
les grandes villes et ensuite je pense
qu'ils ont un fort potentiel parce que
on est dans une période d'effondrement
des grandes idéologies
on voit bien que il n'y a pas de grand
projet commun et finalement l'écologie
est une est une forme de nouvelles rues
les jours et de nouvelles idéologies qui
peut être très puissante et quand on
commence
j'allais dire à endoctriner les enfants
dès l'école on peut se dire que dans
quelques années effectivement ce sera
une une tendance une tendance selon
alexandre de vaincus à raison là la
seule idéologie qui restent en france
aujourd'hui c'est l'eschatologie verte
et bien sûr ses propos d'une portée
philosophique
nous allons terminer cette émission
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi que ce
soit sur youtube ou sur lefigaro.fr et à
demain pour un nouveau en est votre
point de vue
[Musique]